I'm not sure if it's 24-hour news on Fox
and CNN that has caused this I'm not
sure if it's the inordinate level of
prosperity that we have in this country
that has caused this but I am noticing
an increasing every year an increasing
level of drama people have become
freaking drama queens everything's a big
deal a whole lot of stuff that's not a
big deal is now a big deal everybody's
walking around looking for something to
be pissed off about everybody's walking
around looking for just their little
world to get their little toes to get
stepped on and we go into melodrama to
tell each other stories I guess we've
always done that to a degree but it just
seems to an old man that it's increasing
but the drama level is here over year
increasing student loan debt student
loan debt is completely out of control
it's stupid it's over-the-top no
question it's messing with people no
question when people are calling in here
and they got $80,000 in student loan
debt that to the extent that they have
that it's it's not a good thing their
life is bad okay and then you know you
get articles that say things like this
us students have garnered more than 1.2
trillion dollars in outstanding student
loan debt you probably heard that figure
an 83 percent of that debt or one
trillion dollar stems from federal
student loans so we the people have
loaned eighteen-year-olds money we were
brilliant weren't we this has had a deep
impact on Millennials and on the economy
among the 40 million young borrowers an
average student collects $29,000 to
finance a college education a debt that
takes a decade on average to repay the
mounting student loan debt is
debilitating in highlights it's
debilitating in highlights and it has
sweeping economic impact across the
board
Millennials are their lives are ruined
they're postponing home purchases
childbearing marriage and
entrepreneurial efforts because the debt
has weakened the social mobility and
challenged the economic stability not to
mention the total financial success of
the Millennial CNBC article millennial
car buyers are more likely to lease a
car than Generation X and the baby
boomers and Millennials are leasing more
than ever
why is leasing so attractive Millennials
one reason is because you can get a car
that you might not be able to afford the
most popular leased cars among
Millennials Lexus is Mercedes c-class
invented Infiniti q50 lexus RX and BMW
328 these poor freaking starving
debilitated Millennials are leasing
beamers what see what I mean there's a
little bit of a contrast here isn't it
they're apparently not too freakin
debilitated they drove off the Mercedes
lot in a Mercedes I didn't even know
where the Mercedes lot was until I was
over 30 so don't talk to me about being
debilitated you can talk to me about
being stupid but you don't need to talk
to me about being debilitated and the
whole economic culture is caving in on
your poor little BMW head give me a
break they're leasing cars faster than
any generation has ever leased a car and
they're not leasing dodge neons now it's
Lexus IS Mercedes c-class infinity
Infiniti q50 lexus RX BMW 328i did not
give you a car title here that was under
$30,000 not one my first house hardly
costs $30,000 so I don't think we're
really too debilitated I mean we can't
have a baby we can't afford it because
we got to pay the Beemer payment along
with the student loan payment what we're
putting off our entrepreneurial
endeavors the economy is going to suffer
because this entire generations hopes
and dreams are being crushed by student
loan debt while I drive around in
c-class Mercedes what y'all see the
inconsistency in this this is crazy so
apparently they're not as emotionally
debilitated as they are economically
debilitated because they're still making
stupid decisions oh by the way I don't
care if you're millennial or not if
you've got $80,000 in student loan debt
and you go lease a Beemer somebody I'll
smack you silly it's not about age it's
stupid knows no age you can do that if
you're 50 if you want we'll still call
you stupid that's stupid and it's not an
indication that your entire life has
been crushed to the point that
childbearing and marriage has been
affected Oh give me a break now do we
have a student loan debt problem yeah
and we need to get with cleaning it up
yeah but I don't think you're going to
find a pile of money in the trunk of
that Beemer to pay off your student loan
so in that case you probably shouldn't
be driving off the lot a brand new
leased BMW leasing accounted for nearly
29 percent of all new car purchases by
Millennials in 2015 that beats the
average lease penetration rate of 26.7%
for the entire population and is a 46
percent increase in leasing by malignant
by Millennials in the past five years
most expensive way to operate a vehicle
according to Edmunds car guide Smart
Money Magazine and my calculators to
lease a car that's why we call it
fleecing and so what is your reaction to
being deeply in debt and completely
debilitated by student loan debt and you
can't buy our children because of it you
go lease and an expensive luxury car the
most inefficient and most expensive way
to buy a car stupid on steroids and I
don't think you're too freaking
debilitated honestly so really you can't
have it both ways you either got to be
debilitated or you don't and not have a
Beemer or if you have a Beemer you're
just not debilitated I'm sorry you're
just not you know your whole life has
not been crushed both of these things
cannot be there just so incongruent it's
unbelievable a guy actually tweeted this
out this morning that's where I got this
idea James I sent it to James to pull
these two articles up and I just went
ding-ding-ding
that's the truth now are we going to
help you if you're a stupid millennial
or if you're a stupid baby boomer or if
you're a stupid wire or exergy nor
whatever you are yeah we're going to
help you wherever you are because I know
it's stupid looks like I've looked at it
in the mirror for years so we know what
stupid looks like and we'll help you
with your stupid I've done dumber than
this but you cannot cry foul that the
whole economy is stacked against you and
I you know we need a government
intervention and you need to forgive our
student waters and you type this from
your $600 smartphone while driving your
BMW you just can't have it both ways
it's illogical and inconsistent and it's
an indication that this whole culture is
becoming a drama queen so we'll help you
get out of your student loan debt and
out of your leased Beemer but we first
have to call it what it is
stupid stupid now that will debilitate
you stupid will debilitate you this is
the Dave Ramsey show